Julia se degradó a tormenta tropical
efectivamente como se tenía previsto en
su paso por tierras nicaragüenses sin
embargo esto con base en información del
Centro Nacional de Huracanes sin embargo
Julia impactó como huracán de categoría
uno en la madrugada de este domingo la
costa Caribe de Nicaragua en especial el
centro poblado de bluefields donde hubo
desprendimiento de techos
desprendimiento de árboles causó
estragos en todo lo correspondiente al
tendido eléctrico y a la red de
telefonía dejando completamente
incomunicado a este centro poblado Y a
esta zona nicaragüense del centro del
país que es Managua a lo largo de esta
mañana el cenapred que es el sistema
nacional nicaragüense de atención y
previsión de desastres se encuentra con
motosierras cortando los árboles
despejando el área aquellos que han
caído sobre techos o sobre carreteras y
también haciendo una cuantificación de
los posibles daños materiales y de los
posibles heridos a lo largo de este día
Julia estará atravesando todo taza de
agua el gran Lago de Nicaragua y pasará
también por la ciudad de Managua y se
prevén posibles inundaciones y también
deslizamientos de tierra antes de que en
la noche de este lunes salga hacia la
costa del océano Pacífico entre tanto
los vuelos están cancelados en Honduras
Hay 10 departamentos en alerta roja y en
El Salvador el presidente nayib bukele
declaró este día como Día Nacional de
oración para prevenir que hayan víctimas
por el huracán por la tormenta tropical
Julia